so yes because i have attempted to do
this so many times i may have three
minutes left i'm not sure
tech issues ate into that in any case
let's attempt it
see what happens hopefully it works it i
do have the three minutes
less that's a huge bummer
okay okay
all right just everything's breaking on
me it's fine
three minutes of trying to fix audio
really broke everything but it does
sound like i fixed it
and yeah i think i think it's next
weekend or maybe the week after no it'd
be next weekend that we get to play both
demos for a little bit longer
and the game's out in a couple of weeks
after that um
i should inspect that shouldn't i it's
gonna be
oh it's not a key item and there was
something in here wasn't there or did i
just open that no okay
okay but yeah the game's out may
7th i think and i'm definitely gonna
play it there's there's no way that i
won't play it
we will be doing plenty of that okay
really out here right now
scared well okay that's good to know can
i do it could i do it with that
wine glass i picked up or
um but i'm excited oh okay i do need a
lockpick then
of some kind have i already missed it
i thought that i might have
heard
yeah okay
i see
okay
i was expecting to have to find a
lockpick but perhaps not
that's it's dishonored too
or distorted in general actually
i love roasted scraps it's my favorite
material i wonder how different they
gonna make this from the actual game
um i don't know that they will at all
but oh i don't like that i don't
love that for me do i have to touch you
great
well those are noises that are happening
okay so that one's definitely gonna be
something i'm gonna have to fiddle with
oh it's just treasure okay
um we're gonna we're gonna spin you
we're gonna examine you we got an eye
boyos
and this one i can't right oh maybe i
still can
hello you said your treasure so i
suspect you don't have anything
no okay um
is there anything else in here oh oh
oh oh it moved okay
why do i need to run
what am i running from or two why did
you tell me to run
oh [ __ ] oh god okay
is there anything else in here that i
need to pick up this is resident evil
okay
i'm aware of the [ __ ] inventory
situation
it doesn't look like it
okay that's shiny
no all right it's fine
well where have they taken rows
okay is the maroon wasn't the maroon i
oh my god the noises in the last one
the last demo
which actually in australia we generally
call [ __ ] fun fact
oh oh no i'm we're cool with him aren't
we oh
we meet again hey buddy duke i made
myself a friend
here where there's coin to be made
and have you found your daughter no have
you seen her no
if she is truly here the lady of the
castle would have kept little rose in
her private chambers
would she not why would she do that the
very same
oh it is demonstrating take a look lady
demotress you'll get lucky
and speaking of looking here to make a
purchase what what kind of [ __ ] you got
and also do i have money
please do take a look at my new stuff oh
i do have cash i don't know what i need
this doesn't feel like a good use of
time
no i don't i feel like maybe you know
heal all wounds seems good and then
oh
sure these hands are more dexterous i do
like him
though i'll say that
are any of these required i don't think
so let's just buy some ammo because you
know
just [ __ ] just guess some oh god
okay whatever bye i'm ready to go to
lady d's room
i can't wait
didn't expect that to work okay this has
got to be a safe room surely
okay okay okay okay
i think lady d's room is probably
upstairs if i were to guess
okay oh
uh knife
cool i love that for me okay
okay
this game is going to terrify the [ __ ]
out of me the fact that a door
i sold the ammo did i i didn't even
realize that's what i had done
that's how little attention i was paying
so wait how much do i have now
oh no we'll be fine we'll be fine it's
okay now i have more money
that's my bad
[ __ ] okay
okay okay okay
i assume i can't kill her i'm crouching
because i i feel more comfortable is why
i'm crouching all right
you're right them let them letting me
buy ammo would be strange
um yeah i'm crouching because it
i'm just picking up all this ammo you
know it's fine we've got plenty
all right if i need to go back and get
that accidentally sold
we'll be okay
okay okay okay okay okay
somebody got boots in here i don't know
where to go
should i go back up and go up the
hallway
well that's locked
i don't want to leave anyway though
right i'm like looking for
my daughter
great okay well that answers that
that was locked stupid [ __ ] doors
closing i swear to god
i think we got to go up the stairs this
is not the room that you were in
last time because the staircase looks
different how big is this castle gonna
be
um
hello anybody in this big empty room hey
this is where i
have the thumbnail image from this is a
screenshot of this staircase i'm pretty
sure
oh god why is it so open i feel like i
have to whisper because the game's
actually pretty quiet
it doesn't have any music it's like it's
like they can hit me
what is that noise
i don't know
okay nothing in the fire it's like a
waterfall in another video okay this is
accidentally resident evil asmr
[ __ ]
well all of these locked doors are
making things a little bit easier for me
boom oh
you think that she lady deep in touching
this or what
anything negative
okay cool can't wait
hello
in here man
it is true uh jared that i'm trying not
to read chat too much so that nothing
gets spoiled for the record um
but to be fair i wouldn't have known i
had accidentally sold my ammo if you
hadn't told me
just i was just trying to get out of
there didn't even think about it for a
second
um
but yeah the fact that the doors aren't
oh it's just
gonna be some white girls in here the
doors aren't lady de-sized
seems odd okay so this was in the the
first area
i imagine they've changed the items and
stuff though
the winemaking techniques of cartel
dimitris can be traced as far back as
the 15th century long before the current
occupants of the castle
ceno demetresque uses his legendary yet
peculiar technique to enrich the wines
flavor intensity and bestow it with a
thick bouquet her best vintage in sag
sanguis not worth the time i like how i
decided that on the last sentence
didn't think that would work either okay
that's gonna require something with
weight to be put in it
which way okay i'm hoping that i haven't
missed anything in my rush because of
this stupid 30 minute timer
again trying to play it organically
while also
being nervous because i'm being timed
it's not my favorite thing
do you you need an eye you 100 need an
eye
look at you that was in a different uh
place for the first demo for sure okay
oh okay that's a sister i think daughter
ew
oh that's oh that's nasty i haven't cut
open a man
in a while let me this surely isn't
going to work
no no no surely not no surely
that can't this is scripted right
i'm not supposed to should i run
oh oh i oh i can't you you're just gonna
keep coming for me then
[ __ ] [ __ ] i'm not scared though
you know i'm just gonna try and run away
because i think she's just gonna
wonderful no i wouldn't i would look
terrible
can i hide in there no
um well back any longer [ __ ]
i feel like she's i'm not supposed to be
[ __ ] with this i feel like
can you leave me alone ah also this
trigger is
not feeling good okay
it feels pretty [ __ ] love and i would
like you to i can't kill you you can't
be killed
you can't be killed you have to be run
away from there's just no way
but i don't know where to run to that's
not a door alana
[ __ ] get out of my way you crazy hot
girl
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh dang
this isn't going well can she be killed
i don't imagine she can
let me load where did it uh leave me
alone leave me alone leave me alone
leave me alone oh [ __ ] this [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] it
i just want to go in a door [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ]
go away man i'm just trying to get out
of here
no okay maybe i go back downstairs from
here but i'm so lost because i can't see
because of these [ __ ] bugs
is this open no okay okay we gotta find
somewhere to go
somewhere that's [ __ ] open this okay
examine [ __ ] am i missing something
damn okay
i don't want to run out of time go back
to the previous room what does that mean
oh you could make her disappear okay
well i guess good to know that i can't
kill her i do actually appreciate that
i don't want to die though you know i
don't want to die
i don't think i can get through this
door can't do anything to that
this won't open it says it once she's
going to kill me
[ __ ] off dude just just [ __ ] off maybe
maybe just shoot her repeatedly and then
she'll go away right
just for a bit okay this door does not
open
this no that needs a key item
so i've already been in here but i'm
wondering if there is somewhere in here
that i'm supposed to go
aha got it okay cool
hold up well there's you that goes your
ankles there goes your ankles mate
that's not great um not scared of her
i mean i appreciate that i wasn't
entirely clear if i had to kill her or
not like that's a thing that that i kind
of like the mystery of
but not scared of her which is
interesting
she's just kind of cute whereas like
jack i was like terrified of
[Music]
hello
where you wait you got back problems
not because you have to bend though
because all of those titties
i'm sorry
okay cool
please don't get a breast reduction um
all right that's good
i was overwhelmed i'll give it that you
know i was like pretty
i actually know where this is i don't
know if i'm supposed to go this way but
this is
um basically just the opposite of the
the previous demo that was in this area
watch out i can combine those
i don't know how much time i have though
i don't know how much time i have
oh okay oh i didn't expect this what's
this
trust in the light
is that what you meant shoot it maybe
i think i want to break it though that's
what i feel like i want to do
oh neat
okay i figured that one out
pretty quick all right cool oh [ __ ] me
that's dark
didn't you just say trust in the light
dude okay
yeah this is the area from them from the
other demo
hmm
and this place had some really bad
noises last time
yep that's cool
oh god
something bad
do you have anything on you i need to go
to this room first
please
is this a puzzle
okay well i don't love that okay that's
there's nothing in here
okay hey i will say i'm playing this one
with less brightness than the last one
trying to make it look better this does
look really good to me
um all right well could i go back to
where lady d was please
i just miss her man you know she's
something something maternal about her
i don't know if i'm gonna need if these
are gonna lead to a puzzle and if they
are it seems very complicated
in the nine minutes that i have left
jesus
i feel like i'm gonna start walking out
with my gun out
instead because whatever's down here is
gonna try and kill me
for sure okay
[ __ ] why does it make the pickup so
traumatic it's the worst
what are you though i hear you
but i don't see you you sons of [ __ ]
[ __ ]
are they like are they are they zombies
they're just like medieval sort of
oh [ __ ] oh god how many shots are you
gonna take me
[ __ ] oh we got sickles
son of a [ __ ] [ __ ] maybe i'm not
gonna maybe i shouldn't have sold my
ammo
[ __ ] no just gonna back that up a little
bit
all right yeah
okay dude please okay that's one down
i don't know what setting i have this
trigger on that it feels like a button
and not a trigger
no you don't oh no am i in a corner oh i
am in a corner
oh my bad i didn't realize that i was
not aware that i was in a corner
okay cool well don't love this for me
accidents were made
accidents were made i mean mistakes
please stay down
please stay down we have three shots
left
it's not good
i was very panicked and i didn't do a
good job
okay
oh that's you love to see that honestly
though that
is great i wonder if i could have just
skirted them by going through this way
oh no that door's open
okay oh son of a
i don't even know if it's headshots that
are required for you either i suspect it
is
yeah it is how many though ah stop
moving so much
damn you and your well animated problems
when you're too close
shoot you in the knee and then we'll
just run over you [ __ ] that didn't work
okay okay that was still a headshot
we'll take it crystal skull
i'm aware of that film okay there's more
of you
oh well we like a pipe bomb
that means it's gonna be a ton of them
doesn't it
[ __ ] man
okay more ammo cool
son great a [ __ ] [ __ ] they just come
out of the ground
you can't okay should i just pipe them
right now
see what happens it's pretty sweet oh i
can god
oh well you didn't tell me that earlier
uh it's fine i'm just gonna keep going
i'm just gonna keep going because i
don't think i have very much time left
can i open this knew it okay it's gonna
be around here somewhere
many of them are there i believe
cassandra
no she no no nobody no it's fine
you don't need to come back too i'm just
trying to find something to open that
door
okay you could leave me alone and it
would be fine
you're gonna open the door for me is
that why you're here [ __ ] [ __ ]
damn it just trying to go home man no
i'm not i'm trying to find my daughter
and i don't know why i've come down here
to do it but i have
i don't think i can kill you so please
just go away
that's a waste of [ __ ] emma
[ __ ] oh
quit your game i like my voice a lot
would you like some okay chem fluid no
probably not what we're after oh okay
maybe i didn't need to open that door
then maybe i could just keep going
i don't know
is that it was that supposed to happen
or did i do bad
oh that was actually pretty quick okay i
should have i should have
i could have i could have killed more of
them but i was very panicked
so we did it
all right um as this was the first demo
not super scared in these um i think the
sound design's really good and i think
it looks very good
uh and obviously like i'm doing a
panicked rush
that i think is more because of the time
limit than it is because of the context
so it's not like i'm calm
but i don't feel like i'm super scared
um
yeah i don't know i just i feel like
they're very likable
i'm not sure well we did it
we did it super excited for the game to
come out um
and to aim better and to not sell my
ammo you know
just to really be more on top of the
video game
parts of it i'm definitely going to
upload a ton of like let's plays and do
streams
and stuff like that for it too i'm super
excited i really love resident evil
pretty much always have
it's going to be a good time thank you
guys for joining me tonight
it was amazingly very quick uh thank you
this is not the razer webcam actually
well yeah i guess those enemies weren't
too overwhelming they do take a lot of
shots
but um i think that's pretty normal for
a resident evil game especially when
you're like not really well equipped you
don't have upgrades you don't have
a shotgun and all that stuff so
yeah i i agree joshua the problem is
that everyone is too hot
that's the problem i really thought it
would take me a lot longer
um all right thank you all for joining
me glad we finally got this to work
throughout all
of my tech problems um
yeah there's there's one more demo where
you get to play both of them
for a longer amount of time so i might
mess around with those two um
probably do those on twitch because i
think i've already covered both of them
here on youtube
but uh otherwise i hope you all have a
good night and i will see you next time